burn it down all of me we have to stop
him we could have built the future
together I don't think so okay the
development of the evil villain whom
they're calling Megatron mhm and he's
now starting to want to destroy the
world he's going to burn it down burn
sron down to build a new one better on
top yeah which is an interesting concept
yeah because cuz the devil's not going
to burn this place down to build a
better one he's trying to save this one
really good point do you know what I
mean yes so look at what they're doing
by saying now these guys are diverging
and one that wants to burn it down the
devil isn't making a call to burn it
down welcome everybody to a discussion
on Transformers one the origin of story
if you have not seen the video that we
created on the Transformers you might
want to check that out but what do you
guys know about Transformers you guys
big fans seen lots of them know much
about them it's filled by ol enough to
have seen it oh yeah I mean the first
one is 2007 but actually I was uh last
night I went to a restaurant with my
parents and they were playing the
original cartoon you know I don't know
old that Japanese one the Japanese or
like the way yeah I I remember watching
the first one and I think I might have
seen it next one and that was it that
was a kid so do you remember the vending
machines that had like the almost like
bubble little things oh yes and they had
the Transformers the I remember being a
little kid and just wanting the watch oh
no you drained the kitty transformed
into you know something else I thought
that was the coolest thing yeah well I'm
I'm I'm pretty surprised when I started
doing a little bit of research on this
Transformer movie just see the parallels
in like a biblical sense but you know
real sort of twistedness
and we should also mention that you made
an entire documentary talking about
episodes 1 through six so you have quite
a bit of an understanding of these
movies already one through eight and one
through eight okay yes and and and it
was it was kind of like when you see
that pattern you got to really question
that pattern right there's got to be a
reason for it I don't think this stuff
is random I mean you're talking about
different mindsets people that have
written the story that are totally
different this is kind of interesting
this is just coming out right now
Transformers one so I want to show you a
little bit of the trailers and I want
you to see I want to see if you see what
I see okay because I've kind of dug into
this a little bit so I'm kind of like
coming at this from a certain
perspective but um let's watch a couple
of these clips and then uh I want to
talk about it here we go first clip this
is from the
trailer for thousands of years we have
been at War but before we were
enemies we were like brothers I'm gonna
mention we're GNA go through this kind
of slowly so that you digest this
information what what do you see what do
you think right off the top of your head
there's been a war going on for
thousands of years okay is that true
biblically speaking Yeah it's called the
Great controversy between Christ and
Satan okay absolutely how do we know
that it's gone on thousands of years
we're in sin and the Bible talks about
there was war in heaven Satan was cast
out to the Earth and you know the war
continued after Adam and Eve ate the
fruit and sin started on the Earth
what's the traditional time frame that
Christianity believes that we're sitting
here since the creation 6,000 years how
do we know
48 ah you guys are going to put you on
the spot here you know I I kind of dug
around a little bit back calculate from
the timelines that are given in Genesis
you know you've got about 2,000 since
Jesus and you can back calculate from
Jesus back to Moses etc etc so good job
good job genealogy is how we would deter
this and there was actually a um I think
he was a priest I'm not even going to
say his name cuz I don't even know his
name but if you just Google this and you
look it up and he went back and he
actually because you know how it says
how long people lived so he basically
tallied all those things together and
his conclusion came up to be 6,000 years
I that was really fascinating but that's
a that's a that's a true spiritual
statement right mhm and he says we used
to be all Brothers which is okay good
good observation yeah In Heaven There
was a time when everything was okay
there was no such thing everyone was on
the same side yeah there was no sin
nothing good observation until until
according to Ezekiel and Isaiah Satan
became proud and he wanted to be higher
than God or like as high as God right
that's When sin started and he pulled a
bunch of angels with him right so he
said that we were like brothers I I
found that interesting it wasn't that
they were brothers it was like brothers
listen to what the Bible says right here
Keith can you read this stretched out
his hand toward his disciples and said
here are my mother and my brothers for
whoever does the will of my Father in
Heaven is my brother and sister and
mother so right in line with what you're
saying right you picked up on that
everybody was in conjunction together
they were doing the same things the will
of God right and he even Jesus was was
referring to people that are all in line
thinking like that as Brethren right so
I found that pretty interesting listen
to what Romans 8:29 says uh Den can you
read this for whom he fornew he also
predestined to be conformed to the image
of his son that he might be the
firstborn among many
Brethren yeah so even Jesus after he was
incarnated down here he's even referring
to himself as the Brethren right and we
know that when we go back to Heaven
Jesus literally is going to retain his
human form he'll be like a Brethren to
us right mhm all right so I found that
really interesting that this is where
the story is taking place you guys
picked up on that listen to
this what is that sending location
coordinates under
attack it's an SOS message from the
surface fantastic it's time to show him
we are more than meets the
eye a cave with teeth nothing scary
about that all right what do you notice
about this well it says there is a
message coming from the surface meaning
they're not in the surface yeah they got
to be
under the Sur good observation good
observation and that there's something
dangerous about the
surface I found that kind of interesting
like here you have a story where they're
actually in the the middle of this
whatever Earth thing and Cybotron is I
think cyron wait they're in the middle
of Cy Cybotron apparently they don't go
to the surface of and Cybertron is the
evil guy or Planet it's like the city oh
it's a city I thought it was one of the
Transformers like a
planet Megatron Megatron Megatron yes
yes yes so this is Megatron right here
okay but why does he look so different
well it's basically yeah it's an origin
story and they're using a totally
different format but oh I see but that's
Optimus Prime over there and and this
okay so so that they come to the surface
right and nobody no body ever really
goes to the surface I found this really
interesting and then they encounter this
Bean called Primus and here's what
happens when they meet
Primus holy
Primus I see strength in you take these
and access your full
potential we can transform now how do we
use these things come on my head you
choose to use this power is up to you we
roll
out what louder transform and roll out
okay a couple observations I want to see
about this what did you hear so
previously they couldn't transform they
were just in you know this other state
awesome observation because we're going
to bring that up okay so that's great
what else do you see I I'm just thinking
of how why did they look so different
from later on it's almost like like they
look like teenagers basically in like
more clean kind of state I mean that's a
good point I did think about them being
being teenagers as well me obviously
robot's age yeah but they don't have the
powers they don't look as they so they
interact with this Primus character how
did he start this this what was the
dialogue you just heard I see potential
in you is that what you holy
Primus oh that's kind of interesting you
know you know what I mean I know that
they're making it like you know like
holy Batman like that kind of a
statement or whatever like this but I
find it really interesting that that
Primus character is like the god
character and he gave them the powers
okay and then what he did he tell them
they could do with the
powers how you see fit to use these you
use it is that biblical if if if if we
are literally trying to parallel what's
going on with life right here right
Matthew 16:2 24-2 um fipe go ahead and
read this then Jesus said to his
disciples whoever wants to be my
disciple must deny themselves and take
up their cross and follow me for whoever
wants to save their life will lose it
but whoever loses their life for me will
find it so is life really about you're
given the option to do whatever you want
to you want with your life right or
spiritually speaking are we supposed to
do whatever God wants us to
do cuz also there is later in the Bible
I don't remember the verse but Paul
wrote you know and he says don't you
know that you are not your own your own
your bodies don't belong to First
Corinthians B with a price yes and what
happens if Scotty I take you know
something that is yours without telling
you if I get your truck and I just leave
right that's stealing right right right
if I didn't tell you just like leave
with your truck or whatever that's
stealing
I can't do with what belongs to you what
I want right do with my own life what I
want because it does not belong to me we
would be basically stealing from God
right in fact that is the actual basis
of why we're here on this planet to
begin with because God said don't do
something right so we're sitting there
at the tree of knowledge of Good and
Evil going I want it but God said not to
do it but my want overtook my trust in
God yeah I like I like the way that Paul
says all things are profitable for me or
all things are lawful for me but not all
everything is profitable so it's it it's
like showing that you have a choice like
yeah you
can doesn't mean that you should right
right doesn't mean that it would profit
you if you do that but yeah you can you
have the freedom to do it it's like you
have free will yes but exercising that
free will in a negative way isn't going
to you yeah if everybody was left to do
whatever they wanted to do we would have
absolute chaos mhm I believe okay so
that's what the Bible says moving on I
want to help build a better world like
you said we can be so much
more I Want to Build a Better World mhm
it's hard to hear some of that like I
heard something like a bear world I'm
like what a world better a better better
World interesting so what does that tell
you
psychologically this world is not good
enough right that we need to remake it
we need to reshape it we need to reform
it there's not something and what did he
just say in the end it's time that we
are something more than we were created
to be yeah that's kind of a common theme
in movies nowadays what you whatever
you're doing is not enough you should
rise to the occasion you should be
something else be something more don't
accept
the status quo which in a lot of those
movies I think it was in the Uglies too
right they show this perfect world but
then they show that as not good enough
we need to do better and we need to
actually do away with the rules do away
with the laws to achieve that and live
in a world that has no laws yeah it's
it's really just playing on it's
distorting a truth that God has he says
we supposed to you know to grow until
the full measure of the stature of
Christ
so in reality are we supposed to be
better are we supposed to be more yes we
are we're supposed to grow but in Christ
yeah not not just any any other way yeah
he actually the Bible refers to us as as
we are made in the image of God right
can you be more than the image that you
were made
into I mean that's psychologically other
right but that's psychologically what
they're telling them right if you're
made in the image of God and God made
you perfect
and then it's like well we need to be
better bigger better you should be like
God right you know but they already were
like God and that's that's the twisting
of the truth right right yeah and that
that's what we're seeing here where this
guy whom they consider holy they call
him the Holy One gives them power says
do whatever you see fit to use this with
and all of a sudden they can do all
these crazy things um and then they use
their powers to go and create what they
call a better
world but the question is is it a better
world is it really going to improve I'm
really glad that you said that because
this is going to pertain to a clip that
we're going to just watch right how are
they using their powers they say they
want a better world then what are they
doing with this thing okay so here's
what the Bible says right here Isaiah
14:13 through1 15 for thou Hast said in
Thy Thy heart I will Ascend into the
heaven I will exalt my throne above the
stars of God I will sit on the Mount of
the congregation on the sides of the
north I will Ascend into the heights of
the clouds I will be like the most high
and I love this I threw this verse in
here because we often leave this verse
out what does this say Keith yet Thou
shalt be brought down to Hell
to the sides of the sides of the pit yes
so God's basically saying look you're
telling me that you're going to be
higher than me but I'm going to actually
show the world where you your true heart
is and you're going to be brought down
to the pit right Satan is confined to
hear he cannot leave which is a parallel
that was brought up in that Transformer
Series right A lot of people go yeah but
um Optimus Prime sacrificed himself and
and and he wants to save the world so
here's what I would say to that right
Optimus Prime is trying to stop
Armageddon is Jesus trying to stop
Armageddon nope oh in fact Jesus is
bringing Armageddon so you can't take
the model of Optimus Prime and say oh
he's just like the savior because he
wants to save people does he want to
save you from your sin or does he just
want to save your life mhm right so just
because he wants to save you does not
make Optimus Prime like God in fact
Optimus Prime you will see he was
created as a lowly bot and where does he
want to go from there MH okay so listen
to this maybe it's just me but he's
different yeah yeah know I picked up on
that I picked up on that too
what happened my best
friend it down all of it we have to stop
him we could have built the future
together I don't think
so all right what are we seeing now
there's a divide okay the development of
the evil villain whom they're calling
Megatron mhm and he's now starting to
wants to destroy the world he's going to
burn it down mhm so the Cybotron world
or the new world that they're trying to
create yeah I think that they're
probably I haven't seen this so I can't
quite make a a full assumption but I'm
assuming that he's going to burn catron
down because that's where they are burn
Cybotron down to build a new one better
on top yeah which is an interesting
concept interesting because the devil's
not going to burn this place down to
build a better one he's trying to save
this one really good point M do you know
what I mean yes so look at what they're
doing by saying now these guys are
diverging and one that wants to burn it
down the devil isn't making a call to
burn it down yeah I mean Jesus is
ultimately going to burn the world this
is correct and create create a new one
and burn the old one to restart it but
that's not an evil practice what he's
doing is he's trying to save those who
are wanting to follow him take them to
Heaven come back and then that's where
the New Jerusalem comes down to Earth
and the Earth gets renewed through fire
right but the whole reason for it is he
wants to do away with sin right and and
those who choose not to follow Jesus
they would not want to be in heaven
where we are spending time talking to
Jesus worshiping Jesus and if you're
just like anti- Jesus youd rather die
and and have a short burning death
then be in heaven with God that's right
there was a concept that was brought up
in the in the Transformers movies that
we we kind of broke down here and it was
basically saying that for one world to
live the other must die and Optimus
Prime was kind of making a call to the
creators of the universe in um the last
night I think it was and he was
basically like look to the creators he's
speaking to the creators leave planet
Earth alone
I am Optimus Prime and this message is
to my
creators leave planet Earth
alone cuz I'm coming for
you so think about that concept right
Satan is is literally probably wishing
that God would just leave this place
alone let me have this this is mine
right and so the parallel here in the
Megatron series is he's just like
both of these worlds can't exist and
he's like we could have built these
worlds together and he's like nope
there's only going to be one God here's
what the Bible says Isaiah 45 5-6 I am
the Lord there is no other apart from me
there is no God I will strengthen you
through though you have not acknowledged
me so that the rising of the Sun to the
place of its setting people will know
that there is none besides me I am the
lord and there is no other like God is
saying there's only room for one God in
this universe mhm yep and Primus I'm
wondering if he's going to actually then
you know become some kind of God that's
what I'm wondering if that's where
they're going with the series if Optimus
Prime down the road gets revealed as
like he has the god powers or whatever
like this and he's become it but I want
you to remember he was created he was
created low he was a worker and then all
of a sudden now he's wanting to rise up
to the top just keep that in mind okay
here we
go the
stons rise up
incoming come
on awesome that's what I'm talking about
now is the time for us to stand up
together as one
[Music]
so I want there's a couple things that I
wanted to point out you heard him say
rise the Megatron Megatron okay okay
rise I mean that's kind of a really
interesting concept right in the end
Jesus rises raises people from the dead
right and when is the time that the
devil is going to actually rally
everybody around is everybody
yes up is there anyone dead at the time
that Satan is going to try and finally
make a Last Stand people will be raised
from the dead nobody's dead at that
point biblically speaking well yeah
Revelation 20 it's not the final death
it's not the final death but there are
people that are Ren yeah there are
people that are risen from the ground
that's when Satan is loosed from prison
he goes out tother the battle for the
battle of the great day of God Almighty
isn't it interesting how many movies you
are seeing them call and make this call
we need to band together we need to work
together and we need to fight against
this thing and I think it's interesting
that they made Megatron be the one
that's they're Rising they're Rising
that's terminology that's from
God I know we're just lowly workerbots
who can't even transform
don't you want to see what's out
there there's a reason no one goes to
the
surface it's dangerous okay this is
where it gets really interesting the
concept of
narcism nosism is a um a sect a cult an
offshoot of Christianity from the 2
Century ad where they flip the Bible
story upside down where you know Satan
is actually the the good guy and and
Jesus is actually the bad guy and that's
a very simple way of explaining it this
has lots of layers to it and it's still
prevalent today and you can see it over
and over and over again and in fact if
you look on IMDb International Movie
Database completely secular nothing
religious about it you can find Gnostic
movies they tell you these movies are
Gnostic so in this case he's basically
saying no one's ever gone to the surface
don't you want to see what's out there
what's beyond where nobody goes it's
dangerous out there it's literally the
concept of sin it's like oh Satan
telling even a oh don't you want to know
don't you want to try this out and and
explore this yeah and they're going to
find out that whatever's telling them
that the surface is dangerous or
whatever that cause is is lying to them
I'm I'm just going out on a limb here
because that's that's what they're doing
so so what what does nosis in nosism
mean knowledge knowledge
Enlightenment what are they doing
they're going to the surface where no
one's ever been it's all dangerous and
all of a sudden they see this holy guy
and they give gets Enlightenment and
they become transformed I mean come on
yeah wasn't it him that said it was
dangerous yeah megga Dron I mean isn't
that kind of fascinating yeah that it's
actually Optimus Prime going don't you
want to see what's at the surface and
he's the one saying no there's a
boundary here mhm I don't know think on
that pretty interesting all right so
Transformers one I got a couple more
Clips I want to show you look that's
starcream and your shock wave and sound
wave enough gosh raise your hand if wave
is in your name there's a lot of wave
all right what do you
notice uh they look surrounded they're
surrounded they're in trouble they
before a throne what okay there's a
throne what are they
doing they're kneeling oh interesting
they're all kneeling not all I mean
there's ones that
yeah the ones that are in trouble are
kneeling yeah the other ones aren't but
yeah fascinating and you see this a lot
in film the ones that are in trouble the
ones that are saying we need to go
explore you know just like ugly dolls
and all those other films yeah they're
colorful yeah everybody else is like
gunmetal gray yeah that's true the the
the heaven they're boring they're all
the same they're colorless they're great
you see in also that movie the Uglies
hit Netflix recently uh Pleasantville
yeah they're always black and white
they're always gray but those that's the
perfect world but it looks boring and
those who are willing to explore and go
beyond the bounds again searching for
enlightenment they are always colorful
you know somebody somebody brought up
when we were talking about the superhero
Thing and they said do you know that the
the main characters are always prime
colors and they make the secondary
colors as the villains and they're us
usually like the Blended colors and all
that kind of stuff which actually God is
the prime colors so they're even using
the colors in a opposite perspective
like that red yellow and blue being the
prime colors do you know it's also the
colors of Superman yeah I know that's
why I'm saying so Superman and then it's
like when you see the outfits and things
of the other ones that are Blended
colors so here's here's this Throne Room
people and very interesting that you
guys pointed these these things out I
want you to notice um the people that
are on the opposite side as Optimus
Prime how do they how are they portrayed
like what what kind of are they nice are
they mean I just want you to to to think
about this you two come with
me report to waste
management all right Waste Management
yeah not very nice right so what what
observation do you do you make right
here that is a very common story we've
picked this apart a million times why
why is he supposed to report to waste
management
probably because it's a lowly job and
they need to do and they need to do what
they're told yeah so this is both of
them though optim and Megatron like they
got in trouble yes in the very beginning
so so if you think about it again we
were talking about the perfect world
this is the world they have rules they
have laws but it all looks great and
dull etc etc and the leadership always
looks mean controlling if you go outside
sensitive yeah and it's like Optimus
looks like the character that's the
super sensitive one he wants to help you
he's just misunderstood I mean all of
these things are psychological like
tricks that they're playing right mhm
all right here's one other thing that I
want whoo whoo hold up look at his
coloring it's is it blue or purple it
looks a little bit purple it does look a
little purple and green yeah yeah right
purple and green yeah and he's really
super dirty we got these powers for a
reason let's use them
we stand here
together as one
I whoa I got a battle mask it appeared
with this guy knife hands I have knife
hands I can see that
be these are not the bad guys why did
you cut the door what no it was already
like that right yes that's right it was
yeah it was already like yeah okay
observations more I guess you know
coming back to the color you know the
same guys that are like not on their
side they're all boring and gray
interesting that's a really good
observation actually um but he's all
colorful mhm they got new powers yeah
how are they using them irresponsibly
mhm um not sure what to do with them or
mistakenly using them okay so he uses it
right here and what's the first thing he
does when he accidentally um cuts the
door but he knows he cut the door yeah
he denies it and then he threatens
people lies about it yeah I I I don't
think people see through the Simplicity
of what we're watching MH right this is
one of The Commandments mhm like we've
now turned lying into something funny
you better shut up or or you're going to
get it you know what I mean like that's
that's the that's literally the
psychological message that that scene
right there relay oh yeah and and that's
something that that kids will watch yeah
but also like you saying the Simplicity
of the psych psychology in all of this
yeah he just lied well well besides that
what is happening he is taking control
over the perfect Kingdom rebelling
against the perfect Kingdom seeking
power over the perfect Kingdom where did
we hear that before right but again it's
like these little simple messages
because this is a this is done in a
different style of usual Transformers is
really cartoony and kid-friendly and
well kidfriendly and fun and then you're
going to think oh well whatever this who
cares this is not affecting me but um
we've talked about this many times
before mirror
neurons it's it's scient scientifically
proven that when you see something or
someone doing something your brain can't
tell the difference the name mirror
neuron comes from the fact that they
fire both when you do something and when
you watch someone doing something even
if you like don't move a muscle
basically it's as if they mirror the
neural activity of the person actually
doing the thing and they were first
discovered in maak monkeys in the early
9s it's it's Monkey C Monkey do so if
you keep watching violence over and over
and over the Bible talks of by beholding
we become changed it's a scientific and
biblical principle so if you're watching
these kind of movies where underneath
all this the subliminal messaging is
rebel against your maker rebel against
Perfection and and Perfection is boring
and if they don't listen to you you just
point a gun at them and tell them to
shut up rebel against the person that's
on the throne rebel against the person
that's making you kneel I mean there is
a million messages we just watched right
here that are like almost attacking
Christianity like crazy and I think to
be fair to people you know they're going
to come back and say well I'm not going
to get that from
one I agree yeah you're going to get it
from a bunch but it's the same pattern
over and over and over again and you
keep drinking from that well right yeah
and the water isn't good we should
mention too for those at home some of
you might watch this and think this is
really far foot this is stretched go
watch the documentary that Scotty made
we go through all the Transformers
movies until this one in that
documentary and all of them have the
same theme so once you start seeing that
I think you might change your mind a
little bit and then go watch Marvel not
Satan's endgame yes yes yeah because
then what what what that does right
there between those two is you're
watching two totally different series
that have a very similar pattern so it's
pretty hard to deny when you see it
twice like that and you know like when I
was watching the scene right here just
this simple tiny scene right here and I
was like you know what God is asking us
for us to
repent
repent what you got to say you're sorry
you're right I messed up I did something
wrong what does something like this tell
you as a
child I mean lie and get away with it
and then use whatever power you have to
threaten somebody else abuse the
situation or other people yeah I know
that parents have have come up to us and
have said my children were super
rebellious until I watched something
like our documentary The Magic Kingdom
or other documentaries that we made and
they were like now I understand and when
they changed those habits the kids
became fine amen amen well that was what
I got for these uh this particular uh
series that's coming out um this one's
going to drop here in in um uh September
seriously consider these things that
we're talking about I know they seem
subtle to you and um I know cuz you'll
see in the comment section people just
going this is ridiculous or whatever
like this but just think about this
right it was a simple act that got us
into this mess in the first place we ate
a piece of fruit because we were told
not to that's a simple act and there's a
lot of things that God's asking for us
to do simply right to submit to him to
count others more significant to turn
the other cheek there's a lot of
Concepts that we that we are um um
learning about in Christianity and
learning about in the Bible and there is
a lot of things that are being taught
here that are opposite than those things
so at the end of the day pray about
these things do I even want these things
in my life do I please Lord open my eyes
help me to see the truths that are here
if you don't agree with us then ask God
say hey help me to search these things
out and help these things to come come
to the surface but you know also I want
to encourage you guys the only reason
we're coming from this perspective is
because we're picking up our Bibles read
your Bible we're coming into a day and
age when all these messages are just
getting more and more frequent more and
more defiant and um I think that this
stuff is going to ultimately have a huge
impact and it's made for kids I mean
really it's made for kids so you're
planting these ideas in kids's mind so
we hope that you guys find valuable uh
information from our ministry please
check out if this is your first time
welcome check out some of our other
videos we got lots of videos on various
different topics like this but if you
have a question or a comment please we
want to hear about it below and share
this with somebody that you think might
get a blessing from this or or um you
know definitely a simple thing that you
can do to help our ministry go forward
is to give it a little thumbs up or like
check out our t-shirts lightwear do shop
yeah I'm wearing's wearing one Kei and I
are kind of supporting a different
Ministry but yes uh uh well I got the
that's an exclusive VIP t-shirt
drop a comment below if you have one of
these you came to our live event that's
right we're going to try to do that in
the future so keep us in your prayers
but thank you guys for stopping by and
watching we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in 5 minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subscribe to
video bible study on YouTube to help you
along your journey
[Music]
n